listen to me hear my voice  I am here to guide you seeker just as I  guided my flock in the other world we  have the same goal you and I we seek the  girl although for different reasons  this new world has incredible potential  it is freshly born still forming begging  to be crafted by the hands of the new  god I am that God with her powers I can  mold this world to my vision all I need  is your cooperation  your obeisance and in return I promised  eternal peace true freedom disobey me  and you will find that I am a wrathful  those who oppose me are cleansed in the  fires of my guiding light  they become by acolytes my disciples  doomed to burn forever  I am father Theodore and I am here to  purge the world of see  you